if you are psychic mango I knew you're
gonna say that just really no I'm joking
hahaha welcome of this is not happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. some say it
only lasts 15 minutes some people are
gonna tell you it's a mythical creature
that lives at the bottom of the rainbow
some will tell you like overdo it I say
enjoy while it lasts
from the squeegee lamps oh no parties
[Music]
they say that you should never meet your
heroes because you will only be
disappointed
I got an Amen from the church back there
I say go ahead and meet your heroes and
perhaps they will disappoint you and if
they do turn it into material in a
stand-up comedy show which is what I'm
going to do tonight so it was at the
very beginning of my career I was flat
broke I was performing all around town
you know stand-up clubs improv shows
like I mean I would have performed here
but I was just desperate to get anything
going I was doing a little improv show
with The Groundlings and yeah Amen
Church and doing an improv show The
Groundlings it went very well and when I
stepped off stage the stage manager was
literally like vibrating she was so
excited she was like like what is it she
goes Faye Dunaway was in the audience
they don't knowwe oh your performance
and they don't know why you bothered me
to give you this and her hands were just
shaking and I took a movie script from
her hands and on it it said Michael you
are brilliant all caps call me
immediately Faye Dunaway I was like oh
my god I mean you guys all know Faye
Dunaway right oscar-winner legend I was
so excited that like I couldn't wait to
call her and I flew to the valley to my
phone cuz we didn't have cell phones and
I called her up and her the way she
answered the phone was very formal she
said hello this is Faye Dunaway
and it was just like she was in her
movies you know like everything was
serious and dire and I was intimidated
but excited I said I miss Dunaway um I'm
Michael McDonald you said to call me I
saw you tonight
at your improv show I was like well
actually I mean thank you very much but
it's it's actually easier than it looks
and she was oh Michael no nothing is
easy in Hollywood especially as you get
older someday you'll find out what can I
do for you face because I have an
audition for a big Hollywood film it's a
comedy at Universal starring bette no
last names needed all right Midler the
character they want me to audition for
is a boozy christine baranski part boozy
wild pig oh well that sounds very funny
juice that's the problem Michael the
comedy is scaring the hell is
terrorizing me my whole career what do I
need you to be my comedy coach I said um
done um
I charge $25 an hour I can meet you too
much hold on a minute let's not get the
cart before the horse I want you to call
me tomorrow I wake up at 6:00 what time
do you get up like well it's midnight
Fay and I have to read the script and
then you know so could we make it 8:00
I'll allow it
and she she just hangs up the phone and
now I think like I mean I'm so excited
but I also like what happened what do i
what I just agreed to there's there's an
8 o'clock time but I don't know is it a
phone call do I need her what I don't
have time I've got to just read the
script so I excited I do all my homework
I do my diligence and that 8 o'clock I'm
now think like if she calls me do i do I
just hop in the car like Batman
like what happens so I put my car keys
by my landline and I've got the script
with all my notes and I'm dressed up
just to look professional the phone
rings at 8 o'clock on the dot so I just
you know do a little bit and I go hello
Faye how are you how did you know it was
me I go oh I didn't tell you I'm psychic
she goes really
and I go no I'm sorry I was just joking
you know they what you know what should
we do I can come to you you can we can
do the thing at The Groundlings whatever
you would like how would you like to do
this
I'm ensconced right now Michael's just
ensconced can we just do one scene over
the phone and then I realize like of
course I know what she's doing she you
know she doesn't know if I'm any good
she doesn't know what my take would be
and I like her credits she's from
Chinatown and Bonnie and Clyde in
network she has an Oscar and at that
point my biggest credit was leprechaun -
she wants a little bit of a taste
something I get it so um she says I tell
you what you read my part and I'll read
all the others and I'm like what you you
want me to play your part at at you like
give you blind readings and what the
is happening but if you don't fade
down away and you know sure so like I
start doing her part to her and she
doesn't even let me get a couple lines
out before just let me write that down
deadpan
[Music]
let's do another scene and like I'm I'm
so happy to be pleasing
oscar-winner legend Faye Dunaway that
like we just go through each scene we do
another one and she's laughing the whole
time you go up at the end of that
sentence let me just that down like it's
just this maniacal thing but because
she's I'm like drunk on her compliments
so at a certain point I look at the
clock and it says 10 o'clock we've been
on the phone for two hours
she has an audition and Universal at
noon so I'm like fate hold on a second
like I need to get over to you so that
we can really work this out and so you
can get to Universal and she's like
Michael I I don't know let me let me
check my schedule
she just hangs up so now I realize like
the conversations over when you hear the
dial tone so I like I'm kind of steering
by the phone like is it over what
happened at about a half an hour later I
get another phone call hello this is
Faye Dunaway I'm like yes I know Faye I
was thinking about wardrobe what she's
like I was thinking I have a black
Armani skirt it's 9 inches above the
knee which is not appropriate for a
character so I'm going to go to our
money in Beverly Hills and I'm going to
have them alter it for me they know me
they'll do it and I'm like hey you're
like I'm realizing a couple things one
face got a touch of the bat shits
[Laughter]
and two alike I don't care I'm
undeterred I want to help I'm still a
fan I love crazy I want her to get this
part so I realized she needs a little
tough love so I go hey you don't have
time to drive to Beverly Hills
for a fitting with Armani and then drive
all the way to Universal in the valley
you're never gonna make it you can't do
it what are your suggestions
well Fay why don't you just wear that
black miniskirt and if it's too tight
and too short for you throw on some
black leotards and you'll be fine she
was perfect click and like so I just now
I know just to wait by the phone and
coupling this later
phone rings I just go yes Fay what is it
maybe you are psychic Ango I knew you're
gonna say that just really no I'm joking
hahaha
I was thinking about my hair I just want
to put it up in a bun because time is
ticking nice and full Faye that's fine
go ahead and put your hair in a bun feel
comfortable but since you're playing an
alcoholic why don't you pull a couple of
strands of hair just loose so that it
gives you and reminds you of the mayhem
that's going on inside your characters
heart and soul perfect hangs up so now
at this point it's like 11:30 and I've
been working on this thing since
midnight and I'm realizing I'm never
gonna I'm not gonna meet with her and
I'm not gonna get paid like I'm
basically working for free and I needed
the money so bad that again remember
this was calling I start to get mad at
her but then I think you know I don't
know maybe the payment is not in the
form of money maybe it's in the form of
this story and maybe someday 20 years
from now I can tell this story in a
strip club
for slightly less than the $25 an hour I
would have gotten the big that's not
faithful anyway
the phone rings again is right before
noon and I can tell by this this is Faye
Dunaway I'm like Faye no need I got it
and I can tell by the sound she is in
her car she's on speakerphone all of her
windows are down and I can hear traffic
she's like I am right outside of
Universal Studios I want you to go over
the lines with me one more time do the
lines Michael so I'm like alright and
what you have to remember now it's noon
on a Friday lunch hour rush and Faye
Dunaway
is driving a car talking on speakerphone
and holding a script and reading four
different parts with me on speaker so do
the lines so I do a couple of lines
suddenly a year a tire screech of horn
go off and then you're here you go I am
on the right side of the road you're on
the wrong side of the road sir Michael
do the lines the tensions starting to
really pick up and so I'm doing the
lines and it's time for her to now do
her line and she goes I'm Faye Dunaway
like is this it did she have a break
because it is it a psychotic break where
she's just starting at the beginning of
her existence like
so I wanted to help her as a yes yes fat
you are Faye Dunaway yes and then I
realized she's not talking to me she's
talking to the guy the guard gate I was
like uh yes miss Dunaway we were
expecting you all you have to do is make
a left-hand turn
follow the blue line along the river and
then we'll take you to a cape cod-style
bungalow she says thank you we start to
turn because Michael do the lines I
start doing the lines you should get
this pop wonderful I am behind Universal
Studios tour trap I'm going around and
go I'm going to go around
Michael do the lines I can just imagine
like the luckiest tour group in the
world with their cameras and they see
Faye Dunaway like blasting past them but
the flipping the bird doing the lines we
get we get through that and I'm
finishing up and I forgot to mention
that she gave me originally one script
that was different there were different
versions hers and mine were different
and mine had a scene that ended earlier
than hers so I finished my last line and
she goes and I got well that's the end
of the scene there's more I don't know
if they remember you have us you have a
longer scene than I do but mine had was
shorter and it's the later draft so you
don't need to know any of it well that
was the subtext it helps for subtext I
cannot believe you did not write down
all of these things and make notes I
thought you were a professional Michael
I cannot believe I trusted you and you
let me down she's just starts making
noises of rage
it's tears it's rage it's there's animal
sounds like I'm I'm terrified like I I'm
totally safe I'm in my apartment in the
valley I could just hang up but I was
like cribs like a horror movie I was
just frozen like what I'm sorry I barely
could get anything out and then she goes
quiet
I found the bungalow like I was
expecting the little king but I didn't
she's keeping me and I'm not sure why
and so especially after I disappointed
herself so she opens the car door and
you hear the pling pling pling pling
like a ver your car door open and your
keys are still there kind of thing and I
hear a man's voice my bra and then I
hear her go
I know it's not my parking space but I
won't be long I mean guys just like and
so then I can hear face she's just
breathing I'm still there I don't know
what to do she sits back down in her car
and she's just breathing
she was Michael are you there listen yes
I'm here Fay what what can I do for you
it's just I'm just so frustrated I've
been let down so many times and I'm so
frustrated and now I cannot do the
comedy I cannot do the comedy and I
don't know what to do and I was at that
point I like I I got her like auditions
are horrifying they're embarrassing
they're nerve-wracking you're putting
yourself on the line and I mean that's
for me like as a shitty little actor and
an improv troupe
this is Faye Dunaway Oscar winner having
to audition for a part of course she's
frustrated so I just I decided I'd get
into her head and help her out and I
said hey I know you're frustrated you
have every right to be frustrated and
what is an alcoholic but a frustrated
person I want you to use all of your
frustration and I want you to go in
there and turn that into your character
and she goes brilliant
and I thought I was gonna king but I
still didn't get it she was still there
and I could hear her undoing make up and
you're like clicking and unclicking lick
lipstick and all kinds of things and I I
just imagined her looking at herself in
that little rearview mirror and she goes
Michael before I go in do you have any
last words of advice oh yeah I do
actually
I want you to remember when you walk
into that room that you are Faye
Dunaway and her response was thank you
[Music]
[Applause]